[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette édition
d' espace autochtone en direct c'est la
dernière de l'année et nous allons nous
intéresser à l'alimentation
traditionnelle autochtone avec une autre
invitée aujourd'hui nous allons la
rejoindre à sept-îles c'est evelyne
saints-anges une aînée innu bonjour
yvelines ça change
bonjour marie vous allez bien oui ça va
très bien excellent alors nous vous trop
nous nous retrouvons en fait chez vous à
sept îles nous allons payer avec vous de
d'alimentation traditionnelles
d'aliments traditionnels et nous allons
faire avec nos habitués donc isabelle
picard bonjour isabel coixet bonjour et
puis bien sûr hellich queen alors on va
se rendre en fait un peu partout à
travers le pays aujourd'hui autant dans
le nord chez les inuit que donc chez les
premières nations
on va commencer avec vous et évelyne
parce que comme on est à la veille du
temps des fêtes on pourrait parler de
tradition chez les ch et les premières
nations chez les i nous aussi mais
évidemment avant la colonisation le
temps des fêtes ça n'existait pas n'est
ce pas mais ce qu'il y avait est ce
qu'il y avait un lien avec le solstice
d'hiver
justement oui là c'était une rencontre
durant l'hiver que les innocents se
donnait au solstice d'hiver et c'est un
événement où il y avait des rencontres
comment ça se passait ça se passait les
gens avant de partir pour le dard départ
de deux voyons du nomadisme
oui les innocents disait on se rend
compte d'un tel telle une paix que tel
mois et elle est déjà lire les chasseurs
parce que les chasseurs étaient des
pourvoyeurs et déjà ils se parlaient
d'eux
déjà on faisait des réserves
j'attends ça c'est pour le veau m on va
faire la grèce de caribou pour la
rencontre on va faire la viande séchée
pour cette rencontre là ou bien on
regarde on garder les meilleurs morceaux
pour la renconte tank et chez les wade
at il appelle ça se passait comment est
ce que c'était les mêmes traditions de
même chose de tradition chez bwin date
ça fait vraiment longtemps qu'on est en
contact avec avec les non autochtones
donc on a quand même perdu beaucoup
maintenant ce que je peux dire c'est que
effectivement pour le solstice d'hiver
on a encore des cérémonies
traditionnelles qu'on va faire sur la
communauté qui est lui donnent bon dans
une maison longue dans un esprit de
spiritualité donc il ya ce genre de
rassemblement l'a suivie d'un festin le
festin est partie prenante de toute
cette cette cérémonie le et donc il y
avait plusieurs festin mais je peux pas
dire parce que c'est ça remonte à 549 le
quand-même d'enrique ça fonde pas
vraiment cette tradition orale comme les
îles ou encore oui oui vous evelyne
quand vous étiez tout jeune en fait
avant avant d'entrer au pensionnat
comment ça se passait chez vous en
famille à cette période ci de l'année
c'était quoi exactement
est-ce que déjà noël était célébrée oui
déjà
- tu jeûnes et en même temps que je
marque la religion catholique et en des
gens quand on dort mais le soir nous le
nos parents nous faisait dormir et quand
on serait hinault réveiller pour la
messe de minuit est déjà la table était
mise là avait été fait parce qu'on
n'avait pas d'arbres avant il
il avait mis pour le 24 décembre et déjà
il y avait des cadeaux et pour nous
c'était déjà un et même émerveillé et
après on est on partait pour la mer
c'est après la messe ever des des repas
et aussi le
avec mu les cadeaux oui quand vous
parlez des repas qu'est ce qu'on
mangeait à ce moment là on mangeait
beaucoup de départs actés s'était
déporté au caribou des tartes ohashi
côté au grain rouge et où s'ils
envoyaient la laddh hajdin travers les
mets traditionnels alors la colonisation
était entré jusque dans l'alimentation
il y avait des aliments traditionnels
mais il y avait aussi des aliments a
mené par les par les notes oui oui oui
oui
isabelle de votre art et c'était la même
chose ben en fait de ce que je me
souvienne c'est surtout les places sur
la table qui pouvait être différent
parce que j'ai ma mère qui viennent
trois rivières donc qui est québécoise
et mon père donc souvent et quand
j'allais dans la famille de mon père on
pouvait retrouver la banique bien sûr on
pouvait retrouver de l'orignal quand il
y en avait de la perdre ici en avait du
poids sens aussi du côté de ma mère
c'est vraiment un québécois le truc
vraiment traditionnel québécois mais
c'est bien aussi de mélanger un peu
c'est tout c'est toutes ces traditions
là chez les marques également c'est un
peu la même chose on va retrouver parce
que j'ai vécu longtemps à cannes et
s'attaquer où on retrouvait du pain de
maïs en retrouvait
du secteur yal donc différentes choses
mais tous sont mélangés avec dont
quelque chose de plus européenne oui oui
oui oui
aujourd'hui evelyne est ce qu'on peut et
est-ce qu'on peut s'affirmer avec avec
une alimentation traditionnelle chez les
autochtones
oui c'est beaucoup mélanger aujourd'hui
c'est sûr de cela ici ça va être plus
plus difficile parce que le caribou est
à la baisse ça veut dire commencent à
manger de l'orignal on a mangé pas
beaucoup avant et aussi la farine c'est
arrivé avec la colonisation
on a fait la banique n'oscille l'état de
touchants et c'est beaucoup des gens on
a eu un repas traditionnel pour les
aînés qui s'est passé dans le village
hier après midi on a mangé du chameau la
magie du lièvre la marge et la grèce de
queyries beau et aussi on a mangé ce
qu'on a mal joué libé c'est le sentait
ne sait encore rien
ça ne s'est pas senti de l'alimentation
traditionnelle les bim
wii wii fit de la colonisation n'avait
pas les guînes ni le sel poivre
ni la famille l'une soit c'est tout venu
avec la colonisation
oui par contre il est au hédas et si je
peux me permettre au niveau des trois
soeurs quand on parle des trois sarron
parcours mais c'est paul libye
la cabane à sucre l'hôtel on est comme
ailleurs ces deux petits haricots louise
angola bayer mais plusieurs variétés de
haricots verts là c'est pas les longs
marie carré john ami qui fait la
différence
je pense qu'on en avait 25 au niveau des
arts comme des variétés hollande alors
ok on avait le joueur oui oui mais c'est
intéressant parce que evelyne nous
parlait de la banique et puis c'est vrai
que vous allez nous en parlait
d'ailleurs la banique wii qui fait
partie de l'alimentation traditionnelle
mais oui et non en fait oui la banique
eu une place spéciale
oui je peux m'exprimer ainsi dans
l'alimentation autochtone c'est-à-dire
que c'est reconnu comme étant si on
parle d'alimentation de nourriture
traditionnelle autochtone tout le monde
vous dira la banique sni qui veulent
offrir un premier oui par contre quand
on regarde vraiment comment la banique
est arrivé dans nos vies c'est ça qui
est vraiment intéressant parce que l'on
m'a donnée surtout dans l'ouest canadien
les autochtones qui vivaient dans les
prairies les bisons se sont fait
éteindre on sait on connaît un peu
l'histoire et on ne me les autochtones
dans les réserves
et là on leur dit on va vous fournir la
nourriture alors le on étend le
gouvernement oui et qu'est-ce qu'il a
fourni le gouvernement il le fournit de
la farine principalement et de la grèce
alors on devait se débrouiller avec ça
et c'est là qu'on nous a appris à faire
la banique c'est un point d'origine
écossaise l'on combine l'âge de la grèce
avec de la farine et de l'eau donc la
banique vient de cette colonisation là
et elle est colonisée aeio des grands
chefs et là je parle de chef cuisinier
hockey un peu partout à travers le
canada dans reach francis qui est un
autochtone des six nations en ontario
lui il a été un concurrent à l'émission
top chef
top chef canada en 2014 la nouvelle
troisième railway et lui sa mission
c'est justement de décoloniser la
nourriture autochtone donc lui de la
bani qui n'ont jamais fait il veut votre
chasse parce que pour lui c'est un
symbole important de cette colonisation
ah oui est ce que vous en faites evelyne
de la banique pour vous est ce que vous
considérez cela comme un aliment
autochtone pour moi je le considérais
comme
l'argument de colonisation mais jamais
en jeu et on a fait à tous les râteliers
repos mais de dendérah compte de
rassemblement on en fait mais je sais
que dans d'autres communautés comme
n'attache pas de la romaine c'est un
pain qui font à tous les jours c'est un
fait qui est toujours frais ils font la
bonite à tous les jours alain nous c'est
différent à un maillot à sept-îles
pourquoi c'est différent je sais pas
pourquoi nous on peut aller chercher du
pain au magasin à maxime à wendy que je
dis à moi de il ya moins de farine où il
ya moins de magasins dans leur dos
dimaga était là oui oui mais y en
toujours du pain des la banique frêche à
tous les jours et ils le font très très
et très doux et lui ferait chaud puis
très très bon leur pain moi je regarde
si oui oui vous avez bien lu
il est un peu dur mais d'une certaine
manière avec la banique oui c'est même
si c'est le colonisateur qui l'année
vous voulez approprié d'une certaine
manière oui c'est ça de wissant mais en
faisant de la recherche
quand on voit vraiment d'où ça vient y
en a certains certains autochtones qui
sont vraiment pas au courant de ça et
quand on leur apprend le site une
relation amour coulisses peu amer alors
on parlait des bisons parlait
d'extinction des bisons chez les inuit
ça et et l'extinction des chiens de
traîneau ç'a eu le même effet n'est ce
pas ça a changé énormément
l'alimentation chez chez les inuit
d'affaires sommet au québec je veux
parler du québec on est dans les années
50 il ya des agents de la grc qui ont
tué les chiens qui permettait aux inuits
de se déplacer donc
autoriser moyens mais en faisant ça les
inuits et est plus capable de se nourrir
donc était plus capable d'aller à la
chasse aux phoques à la baleine bon
match et erreur et il ya eu des famines
très très importante dans le nord du
québec ici le yop hoy a pas tellement
longtemps il ya eu plusieurs morts
plusieurs centaines de morts d'ailleurs
et donc les légistes les inuits ont dû
se tourner vers une alimentation en can
donc on envoyait des animaux du sud puis
souvent cette bécane de conserve
c'était beaucoup de sous les agents de
conservation des trucs lourd et du jour
au lendemain le à l'intérieur de
quelques dizaines d'années
le mode de vie a changé le niveau
d'activité ont changé aussi on se
déplaçait plus autant qu'avant et
l'alimentation est devenu sucré salé et
plein de grèce
donc tout ça a amené aussi beaucoup de
problèmes au niveau de l'hypertension le
diabète qui est très important donc le
diabète ça vient de ce changement de
mode de les emails pas lui non plus
n'ont absolument pas absolue à gérer ce
genre de nourriture loi est tout à fait
donc ça a été saluée n'est pas un impact
vraiment énorme
chez les nets mais ça on le revoit peu
importe quel peuple qu'on va prendre
dans l'histoire on va retrouver la même
le même patron ml ch les choses tendent
à changer on essaie évidemment de se
réapproprier son alimentation
traditionnelle de base et il ya toutes
sortes d'initiatives qui ont lieu
d'ailleurs dans l'article partout chez
les inuit pour justement essayer de
profiter de cet aliment traditionnel oui
et c'est comme tout les problèmes des
congélateurs communautaire et puis
beaucoup de gens et décrit sa ou dans
les communautés où j'étais qui dit qu'
ils ont essayé d'éteindre tellement les
parties de notre culture et notre
édition
sauf les réseaux de partage de
nourriture traditionnelle c'est quelque
chose qui n'était pas capable de détente
et puis maintenant il ya les
congélateurs et puis si on prend au
nunavik maintenant c'est quelque chose
tout la communauté c'est comme vraiment
quelque chose que tous les communautés
il va approcher la nourriture et puis
ici il est proposé de se tiennent à la
chasse quand il remarque que peut-être
on commence de manquer les choses sur la
radio communautaire pour que tous les
chasseurs se mobilisent pour les remplit
encore et c'est tout cdb du phoque des
caribous vraiment tout et puis tout le
monde peut aller là sans poser de
questions il peut prendre ce qu'ils ont
besoin puis il faut juste que la
personne soit un bénéficiaire de la
colle de revendication de tracteurs de
neuvic d'accord et alors donc les
chasseurs les pêcheurs les trappeurs
vienne et qu'est ce qu'ils mettent ils
mettent leurs prises au complet mais
c'est toujours différent
c'est comme si chasseur va pour chercher
une caribou pour sa famille mais il voit
deux ou trois ils pouvaient à peine sur
les deux ou trois puis les 2 ou 3 il eu
des dons laisse à la communauté oui elle
garde un propre sa femme brooke la
commun et ce en profiter est-ce que
aylwin ça existe ce genre de tradition
de partage aussi chez les innu oui la
question de partage existe beaucoup mais
par contre aujourd'hui nous aux notes
animales c'est le caribou et le caribou
est en déclin
oui et c'est on a beaucoup de difficulté
est ce que nous on mangeait du caribou
en c b
les hôtes y vient du caribou de la base
de notre vie nomade départ des caribous
et 6ème art on se demande si nous aussi
on va mourir la rampe espère on est de
plus en plus convaincant du rsa adapté à
la vie est la vie d'aujourd'hui et c'est
sa note l'auteur peu notre
questionnement est aussi on est prêt à
manger les les autres vient comme la
viande oeufs on en mange moindre
lorgnant mais on mange beaucoup de
castors du parc épais que la perdrix du
saumon c'est les aliments qui novès et
on les garde aussi nous on les garde
au frigidaire on a fait des réserves
quand ces temps de l'auteur de on vous
prend de tout cas trop tard des envolées
conduit et ça c'est pour les fight on se
fait des réserves nous aussi mais c'est
plus individuelle mais ya beaucoup de
rassemblement durant les périodes des
failles comme vous étiez en a eu lieu
hier dans l'après midi et il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de rassemblement et iliad et
les gens se partagent les aliments
traditionnels
est ce que les jeunes générations pour
suivre la tradition est ce qu'ils
partent à la chasse aux castors et au
port typique entre autres maintenant il
faut il faut enseigner maintenant là nos
traditions n'étant périodes
d'enseignement de pour les jeunes filles
reçoivent de l'enseignement par les
écoles les écoles amène les gens à
forest et et c'est dans cette façon là
est par contre dire des jeunes des gens
qui sont très sensibles à la culture et
des gens sont des passeurs de culture
ces jeunes loups et aussi peut-être
quand on parle du castor mettant nos le
castor les les parties l'atteinte ceux
réservés aux aînés les doigts les mains
ceux réservés aux jeunes filles afin
qu'ils puissent avoir des habilités
parce que le castor travaille beaucoup
avec le bois ibb au petit son barrage
figure rugy transporte sont tous ses
sens en bois il est très très vaillants
et il est très habile et c'est pour ça
que je vois les les mains de castor est
destiné pour les jeunes filles pour key
de l'habilité pour c'est de cette façon
là et aussi quand on parle du cas star
quand on dit le mot cadeau le harry nous
il ya le mou castor
c'est quoi le mot dit dites le en innu
dites-nous le en innu un match c'est un
castor 1 mais chic pitch est magique
atteint le mot moche qui est dans le mot
y est inclus dans le mot qui veut dire
je te donne un castor aujourd'hui on
utilise beaucoup pour dire quand je te
donne un cadeau c'est ainsi qu'à
condition à tous les jours je ne te
donne un castor pour [ __ ]
le mot vient de le hockey est roi le
castor c'est comme un genre de deux
cadeaux de présents pour l'aviser tout
pour la parenté parce que dans les
rassemblements dans les rassemblements
des gens on faisait des gens de petits
paquets si on veut dire là où on mettait
du castor on mettait quelques la grèce
de caribou pour le donner aux gens au
retour dans leur territoire et on leur
donnait du un petit sac ou y avait du
castor ses décors vous vous parliez de
la transmission qui se déroule par
l'école mais les aînés eux c'est quoi le
rôle aujourd'hui par rapport à cette
tradition là aujourd'hui c'est ils
doivent donner beaucoup d'informations
c'est 2-2 transmettent oralement de
continuer voire ya beaucoup de deux
livres maintenant qu'ils se font des mdd
entrevue qui se font par l'institut
tshakapesh avec des aînés il rencontre
soit des légendes aude et des chasses
aux des déplacements dans le territoire
et c'est vraiment il ya déjà beaucoup de
beaucoup d'informations
je pensais que le
les aînés maintenant sont dans une
période de transmission et c'est
important en fait oui parce que ce sont
eux qui sont toujours les gardiens de ce
savoir la wii
oui c'est eux qui garde son équipe c'est
intéressant de voir les jeunes parce que
sont toujours surpris comme on parlait
du soir de l'abonné l'histoire de la bo
nuque
ça ça veut dire que quand on leur
raconte des histoires sont toutes
- les comptes a toujours je parle
toujours de 2 avant de star wars au de
batman pour amener à l'imaginaire que
nos sillons non et c'est de cette façon
là au complet les amener à rêver à
regarder on ne sonne aussi puissant
français conter des histoires eux alors
je perds un petit peu le son mais je
vais me tourner vers isabelle si les
aînés sont encore là pour apprendre donc
les traditions et encore des chasseurs
et des pêcheurs on continue ça aussi oui
oui il y en a encore mais mais il ya
quand même des obstacles il y en a quand
même plusieurs depuis quelques années en
30 je parlais à un ami cris qui
normalement fait la chasse annuellement
et lines est que ça fait deux ou trois
ans qui est pas capable de se rendre à
son camp de chasse parce que le
pergélisol fonds en dessous de la route
qu'il emprunte un petit plus du groupe
c'est absolument est praticable donc là
le réchauffement climatique les
changements climatiques la pollution ont
un impact au niveau de la jasse de la
meije déjà il ya plein d'espèces de
poissons qu'on est plus capable de péché
parce qu'il contient trop de mercure
oui oui donc on doit s'ajuster avec avec
cette actualité là qui malheureusement
touche le territoire dans un dans un
premier temps oui mais quand vous parlez
du pergélisol déjà on est très haut dans
le territoire par exemple en est très
haut
oui par contre si on se trouve je sais
pas dans la région chez les innu
par exemple chez les attikameks les gens
vont encore dans le territoire
un peu partout sur le territoire du
québec
il ya quelques semaines entre août à
l'automne ou même en mai chez des et
nous en particulier qu'on appelle le
qu'on va prendre le congé des outardes
ou le gumbri c'est vrai est là et tout
va être fermé ou à peu près dans les
communautés ils perdent le ballon ferme
les écoles parce que c'est des semaines
qu'on prévoit pour aller sur le
territoire et c'est tant mieux
oui c'est un bon investissement
justement pour pour poursuivre les
traditions l'alleud des connaissances
qui vont se perdent autrement si on fait
pas ce genre de semaine
oui oui oui et lige du côté par exemple
du nunavik dans les villages qu'est-ce
qu'on fait également comme travail pour
préserver les aliments traditionnels il
y avait le congélateur dont on parlait
tout à l'heure mais autre chose mais
c'est ça mais aussi comment pas de la
transmission de la culture
on sait que les pressions sur la langue
et la culture tous et additionnelle d'
parce que maintenant des enfants il faut
que ce soit dans l'école toute la
journée et toute la chasse et il faut
dire que dans l'arctique c'est encore
vraiment parce que c'était non plus ne
plus part de l'apd x étaient comme deux
dernières parties d'être colonisés alors
la culture de la chasse est vraiment le
principe d'organisation des communautés
encore mais c'est sûr que les mêmes
pressions sur la langue inuit comme dans
le sud des premiers nationaux du canada
sauf il dit que d'aller à la chasse en
famille et la population de la viande
après c'est transmettre la culture et
aussi la langue parce que même les
jeunes qui parlent plus la langue inuit
couramment mais il connaît toutes les
mots tout les processus de préparer la
viande parce que les concepts existants
en anglais ou en français au nunavik
alors il faut prendre les mots les
concepts et technologies pour apprendre
à leur ai dit c'est encore une volée
très puissante pour transmettre la
culture puis la langue aussi et dans les
grandes villes on est capable aussi de
faire cette transmission est ce que les
réseaux de partage existe aussi dans les
grandes villes
et est ce qu'on enseigne aux jeunes
aussi ben évidemment la tradition qui
vient avec ce partage là mais je dirais
quand tu as manquant pas de grand
dans l'arctique en parle de comique à
ses 7000 tonnes ou bien sûr personne
puisque maintenant mais ce qui est très
intéressant c'est avec le réseau de
partage ce même pour les gens peut-être
qu'à louis de salaire pas grave mais
c'est une ville avec toutes les services
des municipalités tous les programmes et
ils ont le centre d'accueil aramark pour
les années avec alouettes et chaque
jeudi
ils ont un langage pour les aînés c'est
juste la nourriture traditionnelle et
les gens qui en charge de programmes ai
dit que ça c'est comme les journées le
plus populaire pour le centre d'accueil
et pour la nourriture et l'achète sa de
la magasin de nourriture traditionnelle
et kalaweit ok mais et de programmes
finance tout ça soit les programmes et
quand même les gens etc alouettes
viennent tout le temps au centre
d'accueil pour donner la nature pour
fait légaux nation parce que c'est
tellement même dans une ville et il
devrait y kalou était plus cette idée de
9 à 5 ce n'est pas dans le village de 2
300 personnes
mais quand même c'était tellement une
partie de la culture ça reste encore et
c'est juste une p'tite anectode si vous
me permettez le coordinateur du
programme expliqué que au début de
décembre
ils ont reçu une donation des rues nac
sosa c'est la mort ce fait monter et je
sais pas si vous connaissez ça mais le
monde ces chasses et puis c'est enterrer
y mettre les roches déçu ça fait mal et
même avant la colonisation nommément
cité préparer pour manger en hiver et
juste à cause de ça avec le temps c'est
pas un repas de noël mais c'est juste
parce que sa conversation avec l'hiver
suivant c'est quelque chose que les gens
mangent plus autour de noël
un festin oui et puis ils ont reçu une
donation de seul le 1er décembre ça
c'est que ça prend du temps la
préparation médicale ou 8 les gens se
préparer ça pour amener au centre
d'accueil pour les aînés et puis le
cours de notre programme et il roule
encore sur cette donation encore parce
qu'il ya tellement ça aussi c'est juste
on voit que même dans les milieux
urbanisés de l'arctique que tout ça se
tiennent en gros on every yvelines est
ce que oui parce qu'on parle de
l'alimentation mais l'alimentation puis
hellich le disait la langue la culture
se transmet aussi grâce par exemple à
l'alimentation parce qu'il ya tellement
de mots qui sont liés aux aliments à la
façon de les préparer n'est ce pas c'est
sur wii toute la mais si on prend le
chasseur qui s'en vont au karibe où il
fait le dépeçage et déjà la façon qu'ils
veulent dépecer son carré beau il voit
s'avancer pour le la nourriture ou c'est
pour des vêtements c'est pour des
graisses la grèce du caribou et des gens
les jeunes doivent savoir quand on fait
souvent il ya des dépeçages de caribous
avec des gens les enfants sont sont
habitués à ce langage le langage de
dépecer tel morceau de viande et et ses
visuels aussi maintenant tout ce qu'on
fait on doit le faire visuel on le
c'était une technique traditionnelle et
on utilise souvent encore cette façon et
les jeunes victimes de cette façon oui
il voit donc ils le retiennent beaucoup
plus facilement le fait de le voir et
d'exprimer les mots qui viennent avec
aussi oui oui on parle d'eux on parle de
ce que mon alimentation traditionnelle
de ce qui a été amené aussi par les non
autochtones
mais les non autochtones isabelle qu'est
ce qui retire de tous cette tradition
alimentaire autochtone mais je trouve ça
très intéressant comme question parce
qu'il ya plusieurs choses en fait puis
on le remarque pas souvent comme comme
québécois nommés on identifie pas
toujours je pense bien sûr aux produits
de l'érable dans un premier temps
l'érable je veux dire les européens
savaient pas comment faire couler en
érable et donc tous les produits dérivés
ça provient des autochtones le maïs
c'est la même chose oui le maïs pendant
longtemps été snobée par les européens
10 dans la colonie française était
réservée aux vaches et le dresser des
morts les animaux oui on se consommait
pas nos enseignements et tranquillement
on a découvert le maïs à éclater bon
oeil manimise l'estivé aceh terror est
donc aujourd'hui ça fait partie de
l'alimentation québécoises canadiennes
ya aussi le topinambour donc ça
ressemble un petit peu bataoui la voix
ça c'est ces indigènes le café bien sûr
amérique du sud oui oui oui non
important oui le chocolat la canneberge
bons amis les lanaudois souvent
finalement on l'emploie de moins en
moins c'est dommage parce que c'est un
mot autochtone wendat si je me rate
aucun câble d'accord on arrête de dire
canneberge
oui on va d'économiser faire tout ce qui
est les techniques aussi de fumage du
poisson les français ou les européens en
général
eux ils salle est plutôt où il séchait
oui c'est vrai tandis que nous enfumer
donc ça c'est une démo 6 et que c'est
transmise et dont les sauvages les
courges les narcos dont je parlais tout
à l'heure donc tout ça ça vient d'ici le
tournesol bon et je tairai ya quand même
plusieurs choses dans l'alimentation et
on le 6 mai tellement pas c'est quand
même incroyable oui est ce que les
jeunes les jeunes à la maison
toi m vous isabelle nouveaux jeunes à la
maison savent tout ça mais c'est sûr que
chaque fois que je fais de la nourriture
traditionnelle je le mentionne
j'ai fait de la bahn et qui a pas
longtemps je leur ai expliqué d'où ça
venait
puis des fois ben haussé de l'orignal la
première fois je me souviens qu'ils ont
vraiment noté que c'est une viande
différent oui oh non pas importer à
l'orignal c'est un peu la réaction que
j'ai eu
donc je leur ai fait je l'aï fait goûter
finalement c'était possible mais je
voulais pas à chaque fois ils chialent
donc des fois j'en passe quand même dans
la vidéo c'est pas d'accord finalement
plus vieux jeu la règle mais c'est une
manière de s'y sont élevées en ville
donc c'est vraiment un complètement
différent puis mais dont ma génération à
moi c'était on avait quand même la
nourriture aussi traditionnel dans ce
qu'on mange et on est on est comme plus
habitués mais la nouvelle génération
comme evelyne le mentionnait tout à
l'heure je pense que c'est important
qu'on contre ans médecin parce que sinon
ça va oui oui oui
evelyne de votre côté jeu
c'est que vous avez de plus en plus de
petits enfants autour de vous et vos
enfants rue des enfants aussi est-ce que
lorsqu'ils viennent à la maison vous
leur enseigner tout ce qui vient de la
de l'alimentation traditionnelle
autochtone
comment vous la fait cette transmission
là on l'a fait journalier quand on les
raconte surtout les enfants et souvent
moi ce que le plus souvent ce que je les
emmène à forest et c'est de cette race
alors que la transmission se fait on
il paraît que la semaine prochaine pour
la forêt puis vont venir ce mal là vers
la fin de semaine après le 1er janvier
et ils vont retourner à forest à la
semaine de relâche et pour moi ça c'est
des moments de transmission qui se fend
et avec les autres maisons enfin on a
fait on a fait tout le chemin les
portages qui rend fort est le chemin des
i nous et on je les fais avec mes
enfants pour moi c'était un héritage à
laisser un héritage titre est très
important mais en ce moment le garde
manger des premières nations il doit
être assez viviani ya un gouvernent et
je maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on trouve à
ce temps ci de l'année en forêt par
exemple aujourd'hui il ya la perdrix du
lièvre
tu peux faire des trous la glace les
chercher du poisson tout seul en forêt
facilement on peut avoir deux
d'alimentation traditionnelles oeil aux
beaucoup de perdrix et aussi je voulais
quand même vous parliez de nous les i
nous on n'a pas beaucoup de on faisait
pas de culture vient du taux en prenait
on prenait les animaux qui se
présentaient à nous on faisait une
raison
pour les bleuets ou les gie côté mais
par contre comme un conte conserver
notre notre nourriture nous aurons le
conservait d'une façon soit le boucané
le fumé et c'était une façon est aussi
le laisser à l'air et même on n'avait
pas le ciel et on le laisser à l'air ça
faisait comme une couche qui protégeait
la viande est aussi on pouvait fuir les
enfants sur l'île le voir régulièrement
la façon de cuire le le voyons circuit
du castor ou des eaux tarder on voit les
attacher les ficelles et on va faire un
feu oui et les vient vont se cuire vont
se cuire très limpide également on fait
aussi la cuisson sur le sous le sable on
fait on peut faire du pain soul ça on
peut faire des dfm sous le sable en cuir
notamment sur le sable le som envol
enveloppées dans de dents du boulot les
corses de boulot et on voit bien
l'attacher et on voit le cuir sur le
savent garder les techniques de cuisson
qui qui sont différemment et aussi à des
techniques de conservation qui sont
différents d'ailleurs j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses en disant le livre de
michel 2007 jean-louis coucou mme parce
qu'ils en parlent beaucoup comme en
cuisine est de la manière traditionnelle
est ce que vous me dites là ça me
rappelle exactement ce qu'il raconte
dans son ouvrage
alors évidemment pour nous non
autochtone l'idée pour découvrir la
nourriture autochtone c'est d'aller dans
les restaurants et isabelle y en a de
plus en plus qui nous permette d'aller
voir c'est quoi l'alimentation
traditionnelle
oui oui il y en a vraiment commis
plusieurs depuis au québec ça fait pas
tellement longtemps là ça fait une
dizaine
dan est peut-être encore les voir
barrette mais déjà dans l'ouest canadien
à vancouver par exemple y en a qui est
extrêmement connue mr bannock entre
haute sâone bannock c'est souvent des
petites avec bane hommes ayant des
winnipeg si on regarde au niveau du
québec il ya un nouveau restaurant qui
vient d'ouvrir il n'y a pas tellement
longtemps juin si je me trompe pas qui
est à montréal donc c'est la chef
normand kondoki et micmacs qu'il a
ouverts et ça s'appelle le micmac
qinghai dans l'ouest et dans l'ouest de
l'île sans sa star mais finalement le
couvert quelques places pour pouvoir
recevoir des gens oui il y à la très
célèbre sagamité dans le coin de québec
lyne vue non il y en avait un restaurant
dans ma communauté à wayne d'accueil
maintenant ils ont ouvert dans le vieux
québec
il ya également le restaurant la traite
à oignies également qu'étant et reconnu
donc il y en a plusieurs comme ça et il
y en a en particulier que j'apprécie qui
est acquis situé à montréal
c'est le café la maison ronde que vous
connaissez peut-être c'est dans le
square cabot et chaque été sa ouvre et
sa emploie des autochtones qui sont soit
itinérant ou donc à la recherche de
trouver suffisamment vraiment tout l'été
c'est un beau projet communautaire
social en fait on aimerait la voir à
l'année par exemple là ça serait
vraiment intéressant
oui mais évidemment on le voit
heureusement qu'il ya des gens pour
poursuivre la tradition mais il ya aussi
les dangers des changements climatiques
qui affectent aussi le garde manger des
des premières nations mais aussi des
inuits hellich oui si on parle de la
situation nous nati avec par exemple
c'est un peu comme un homme sinon j'ai
dit tout à l'heure avec le choc des
caribous s l impact énorme énorme sur
les côtés de québec et terre-neuve aussi
et on a tjrs à vue dans le même réseau
de contributeurs communautaires comme
dans les autres régions inuits
mais avec le juteux les caribous et puis
surtout le troupeau de la rivière george
est juste produit maintenant la dernière
fois qu'ils ont fini toutes là tout
c'était avec le règlement nous
des inuits du québec inuit de
terre-neuve et puis les gouvernements
aussi provincial et puis la situation
dans ses 5500 caribou qui a chuté de 99
% dans 20 ans évidemment c'est quand
même difficile de saisir et à cause de
ça y est plus des caribous dans les
congélateurs communauté ou une ati à
voûtes
mais il ya un programme qui commence et
autour de 2013
et ils ont ouvert la chasse aux orignaux
dans le parc de chrome os qui est sur
l'île de terre-neuve
oui et il peut mettre le de chasse deux
orignaux s'est découpée à terre-neuve
puis emballé à terre-neuve il envoie sa
dent nunatsiavut pour remplir les
congélateurs communautaire alors c'est
c'est très bon c'est une façon de faire
fonctionner ça mais comme on n'a pas du
tout alors là on manque cause de
changement climatique
là si notre rupture entre la
transmission des cultures entre
générations mais oui bien sûr où et qui
le caribou aussi c'est c'est dans le sud
la boule d'or ça l'aurait nyassa se
chasse mais c'est vraiment le caribou
c'est ça qu'il décrit tout tourne autour
de sammy alors c'est bon que sept
programmes là mais il ya un impact et
puis quand j'ai parlé avec le canton
allègrement du nunatsiavut cette semaine
il dit qui pense c'était 30 ans réunion
qu'ils ont eue cette année mais il dit
pour toute l'année nati à voûtes
oui c'est un grand animal mais c'est
quand même passé c'est pas comme dans
chaque communauté on peut chasser ce
qu'on a besoin puis alors c'est comme en
voit déjà et comme les inuits et une
culture tactique mais on voit beaucoup
qui se passe à nous lancer à bout de pau
mieux comprendre ce qui peut arriver
pendant que les changements il ya
vraiment hausse à menton au nord parce
que c'est l'écriture arctique de plus au
sud au canada
alors c'est toujours intéressant de voir
qu'est ce qui arrive le quel programme
est en place pour répondre oui
isabelle est ce que l'alimentation
autochtones toute la richesse qu'on
retrouve dans le garde manger des
premières nations
est ce que ça peut être un élément on va
encore dire le mot mais de
réconciliation oui oui je pense que oui
absolument mais je dis oui de manière
très affirmée mais il y annonce je
recommence de par le monde à l'eau si
vous présentez un restaurant autochtone
donc n'importe où au canada vous allez
pardon jeu désolé ça sonne donc vous
allez pouvoir déguster bon du sol on a
des trucs qu'on va voir dans tous les
autres restaurants mais vous pourrez
jamais goûté à l'orignal la perdrix du
castor du porc-épic moi j'aime pas ça en
pensant mais bon on peut pas offrir ces
produits là que normalement dans les
cultures autochtones on va chercher de
génération en génération
parce que la loi les lois provinciales
entre autres ici c'est la map pack ne
permettent pas d'offrir ces éléments là
puisque tout aliment qui est servi en
restaurant doit passer par l'abattage
oui et donc là c'est très compliqué il
ya un programme pilote qui existe au
québec depuis quelques années qui permet
à quelques grands restaurants plus on
parle de cinq ou six de pouvoir servir
de l'orignal entre autres et aux médias
oui mais c'est vraiment très très rares
sinon on va pouvoir trouver du wapiti
parce qu'il y ait des élevages de wapiti
on peut trouver du cerf dans le
chevreuil parce qu'il ya des élevages
mais les autres animaux disons que ça va
être beaucoup plus rare ça va être plus
difficile a ajouté le meilleur moyen
c'est de participer à un pas au festin
là ça va arriver dès fois que dans nos
communautés on va en servir on peut
goûter au parquet pékin aux castors bon
jeu au pied
alors donc l'élément négatif mais
vraiment positif c'est quoi en fait si
vous vous rendez dans un restaurant bien
sûr on est toujours content d'aller dans
un restaurant on rencontre on peut jaser
on est dans un resto autochtone donc on
va vivre la culture avec bon la
décoration on peut poser des questions
sur ce corps manche donc ça permet un
échange là
nourriture ça a toujours été le cas donc
oui selon moi ça ça peut être un moyen
de une porte d'entrée 1 pour connaître
davantage les premières nations
on dit souvent qu'on connaît par les
sens bien là on parle d'europe are will
par le toucher par la vue par par le
goûter vraiment on est vraiment au coeur
de cette réconciliation oui oui et puis
combien de traiter combien de
d'événements se sont passées autour d'un
buffet banque est absolument c'est
vraiment un lieu de festif de rencontre
et même dans nos communautés on a encore
des festins communautaire où on va
servir de la nourriture et ça va
rapprocher les gens c'est vraiment
important oui d'ailleurs parlant de
festins communautaire evelyne votre
prochain festin communautaire ça va se
passer ou avec qui comment le prochain
spectacle et la première fin de semaine
de du mot doux c'est le festival de
musique
depuis je crois qu'il faille de sa 35e
anniversaire et demandé pardon oui jma
general en fait bien sûr oui et tout
québec est invitée à ségou et à ce
moment là
là il ya des repas vraiment
traditionnelle vous pouvez boire
comment ils font cuire le pain sous le
sable vous voyez des castors des des
outardes saumon fumé
si vous voulez venir manger nous on mets
traditionnels c'est à ce moment là parce
que c'est il n'y a pas de restaurants
plus tôt et qui sont ouverts de avait
cloué le mets traditionnels oui oui le
temps se termine déjà certainement
passer à la evelyne avant de vous
quitter dites nous quels sont vos
souhaits pour 2020 on on est obligé de
parler d'alimentation là mais en général
dans la vie quels sont vos souhaits pour
l'année à venir
moi ce que je souhaite à tout le monde
on avis vincent
toutes les premières nations et les
québécois que l'on passe une bonne année
en s'impliquant commencent à se parler
et de se comprendre aux six mois si le
souhait que pour 2020 voilà merci merci
beaucoup evelyne saintonge d'avoir
assisté à cette émission d'y avoir
participé
nous vous souhaitons la santé et bien
sûr une très très belle année merci
merci beaucoup
à très bientôt et isabelle je me tourne
vers vous quel quels sont vos souhaits
quel est votre souhait pour 2020 belle
journée plusieurs le premier ça serait
d'ordre politique d'améliorer les
relations avec le gouvernement
provincial et les premières nations là
on l'a vu à la lumière des derniers
événements d'actualité qui commet un
en-avant vraiment une dissension oui
sinon j'aimerais vraiment qu'on se
tourne vers les enfants vers l'avenir
les enfants autochtones mais pas
seulement autochtone moins que les
remettre au sein d'une de nos univers
comme autochtones et allochtones je
pense que ça serait vraiment ingrat et
souvent ce sont les événements
politiques qui ont de la difficulté à
vouloir marier oui exactement ça rime
est en effet de rui j'avoue que c'est un
très beau souhait et licha souhaits pour
l'année 2009 1 jusque les voix de
l'arctique soit plus représenté dans les
discussions de changement climatique
dans le ring je dirais que ce serait bon
pour tout le monde de prendre si ce qui
se passe et pourquoi
voilà merci merci beaucoup à tout les 3
je vous souhaite une très très belle
année ainsi qu'à vous à la maison très
belles années 2020 nous nous
retrouverons ici même sur ce plateau le
10 janvier prochain
à très bientôt au revoir
[Musique]
je
il